it's great to be joined today by Steve
keen who is an economist professor at
Kingston University London also author
of several books including debunking
economics and most recently can we avoid
another financial crisis now crowdfunded
on patreon at patreon.com slash PR of'
like professor Steve Kean ke en Steve
great to talk to you thank you for being
with us a lot of to be asked so this
topic of realistic economics has been
really interesting to me for a long time
and I think it's a really important
issue in general because it affects so
much policy that our elected officials
are talking about all the time so maybe
like at the top level just to get our
audience into the idea of what you're
discussing here what is not realistic
about how economics is mostly taught at
the college level well the answer that
is almost virtually everything but I
think I should start from a wonderful
quip from that brilliant American
satirist so mentioned many many decades
ago and he said that to every human
problem there is a solution which is
neat plausible and wrong and that's the
situation with economic theory it looks
neat
it looks plausible but when you dig into
the foundations it's actually wrong so
for example it take I think the simplest
example this is the one that I start my
lectures with of my students at Kingston
and that is the idea of the supply curve
now the idea of the supply curve you
know you do the classic drawing it every
economics textbook has and I think it
inhabits the mind of economists a very
very deep level is argyria intersecting
supply and demand curves as supply curve
that slopes up because people think that
this makes sense to you if you want to
buy some more or something that's going
to cost more so that's what people think
at the plausible level but when you look
at what actually arguing they're saying
well the risen price rises is because
the productivity of your variable input
which is laid by fundamentally Falls as
you produce more output so you have a
increasing level of output are you
paying the same wage for a worker but
each worker is producing slightly less
than the one before therefore your cost
per unit Rises that's why you have a
rising supply curve it is empirical
nonsense it has been torn apart
by something like about 40 or so surveys
the last one being done by Alan Blinder
who and he did it was a vice president
of the American Economic Association so
I'm not talking raving radicals here and
what he found was that when you asked
firms what their cost structure were
they had constant or falling marginal
cost they didn't have diminishing
marginal productivity at all and the
reason is quite simple thankfully
economists do not design factories
engineers do and they build them so they
as they approach capacity they become
more efficient they which maximum
capacity when the factories could at
full at full by usage stage you normally
build a factory and started with about
say 70% capacity because you're
expecting growth over time and as you
approach that peak level of performance
your costs actually fall so let me see
if I rather just because our audience
our audience may not be let's see if we
can just rephrase so we can make sure we
are so there's this idea that in basic
economics that as you supply more of a
widget for example that the cost to
supply that widget is going to go up but
that in practice what actually seems to
be the case is that you are able to
reduce the cost per widget as you
produce more because of efficiencies
that exist within manufacturing to take
the factory example is that more or less
what you're saying yes the factory is a
production line you design it to work
best when the factory is going
gangbusters you build the factory with
spare capacity as you approach
gangbusters scale your costs actually
fall so rather than a rising supply
curve of anything that should be a
horizontal or falling supply curve and
once you do that the entire theory of
economics starts to unravel and that
applies to so many points in the theory
that it's almost beyond cataloging them
all let's talk a little bit about the
the sort of rational actor theories of
economics I've spoken extensively about
the work of behavioral economists
including folks like Daniel Kahneman and
so many others and there are so many
different data points that we
increasingly have which tell us that the
idea of sort of standard
economics that every participant in an
economic system is always acting
completely rationally on the basis of
the information that's available is
simply not true but yet the idea still
continues to persist what is your
assessment of the best way to understand
why the rational actor hypothesis simply
is not realistic
well simplest reason is because the way
they define rational if you actually
took out the lift the word out and gave
the definition that they give it what
rational behavior is what it comes down
to is people have a model in their heads
which is able to accurately predict the
future now if you told somebody here's a
definition what's the word that goes
with it they wouldn't use rational
they'd choose the word prophetic mmm or
say what they actually build a well they
actually call rational behavior is
prophetic behavior now I'm sorry I'm not
rational because I don't have prophecy
is one of my skills and and and I hope
it's the reason they've actually got
this concept is because they would have
liked the market to dominate even if you
had irrational behavior they would have
liked that outcome when they did all
their various bits and pieces of
modeling they aren't that the market
would not reach equilibrium it wouldn't
reach the ideal point so they because
it's pretended that we could actually
predict what that ideal point should be
and move to it anyway so effectively
their idea of rational agents as saying
the whole that your universe is
inhabited by gods who can predict the
future accurately in which case what do
they need a market for so it's actually
a failure of the theory but it's
disguised by the use of language is
there a case to be made and I asked this
sincerely not in a rhetorical way or
with any kind of preconceived notion is
there a case to be made that despite all
of the failings and inaccuracies that we
now know exist with the sort of
traditional schools of economic thought
that there is still some logic to
starting with that because it does
create a framework which we could then
explain the failings of where if I think
back to microeconomics 101 and
macroeconomics 102 in college I now
understand why what was presented there
does not make sense but I'm curious as
to whether if I had jumped right in
to behavioral economics and some of the
other things that you and I are talking
about and are going to talk about I
would have lacked the foundation to then
understand why it doesn't make sense if
my question is clear well you understand
what the theory doesn't make sense but I
think what it actually does is it
distracts you from what's actually
interesting about capitalism because
what it's about fundamentally telling
you as a capitalist system that reaches
equilibrium and if we make a few little
assumptions like all goods like all cars
are the same and all TV shows are the
same and so on homogenized in this to
make it easy to understand in fact
what's special about capitalism is not
equilibrium at all it's far from
equilibrium behave if you're pushing you
to innovate and and consequently the
theory itself distracts you from what's
not just what's bad about capitalism
what's good about it and I would rather
say let's start all over again and begin
with an evolutionary framework and say
what we see in capitalism is an
evolutionary system and compared to
previous social systems like feudalism
and socialism for that matter there's
far more innovation far more
revolutionary change in capitalism and
that's a good thing and then we could
start from that perspective and get a
very very different view of the world
which would be more accurate so in other
words if I hear you correctly you're
saying that the way economics is taught
gets both the failings and successes of
capitalism wrong yeah you don't get any
explanation for example in a
conventional economic theory of why
growth occurs you simply say there is an
improvement in technology over time now
I would like to understand why does
technology improve what are the factors
behind it and if you read Shawn Pater
for example is a very much a non
neoclassical economist it gives a
wonderful explanation of why capitalists
innovate and why that sort of level of
innovation didn't occur in a feudal
system and another non-orthodox
economist called Janos corn I it was
Hungarian and trying to understand why
Sascha lists economies grew so slowly
developed a concept with what he called
demand constraint versus resource
constrained economies saying that
socialist a resource constrained and
therefore you try to make last year's
product in a larger scale whereas
capitalist ones of the demand
constrained and to grab hold of that
demand
you need to innovate more than your
competitive house that's a much richer
appreciation of capitalism than what you
get out of neoclassical theory what are
the political implications of these
fundamental misunderstandings of
economics and how its taught and and if
you want to get into specific policy
that is sort of put on the back of bad
economics that I think that would be
interesting whether it's tax policy
understandings of debt and deficit
austerity measures whatever like how
does the foundational problem of how
economics is taught lead to elected
officials making bad policy I think the
best air is the financial system because
that's not one that I actually raising
your left versus right political
feelings about it it's obvious the
financial system failed in 2008 why did
economists not see that it was going to
fail because they convince themselves
they could model capitalism while
leaving the financial sector completely
out of their equations so they weren't
even looking at what caused the
financial crisis at the same time they
are advising politicians that it was a
really good idea to deregulate banks to
expand their operations and don't worry
about the level of private debt that's
irrelevant now that's completely
disastrously wrong advice it's like
telling a captain of a titanic don't
don't worry about icebergs and ice
fluffy things that can't hurt you so can
you go into more depth about that I mean
when we think back to the 2008 financial
crisis there are sort of not necessarily
competing explanations for it but
certainly differing explanations in
terms of the importance of any one
factor whether it's deregulation
mortgage crisis cyclical downturn etc
how would you is it even possible to
start to unpack what is actually the
initial catalyst for such a downturn
absolutely and this has been 30 years
doing this and there's plenty of any of
my successors and co-workers have done
the same thing
it was credit we had too much private
credit and the simple dynamics is that
credit which is borrowing money from
banks adds to the money supply and adds
to the amount of demand in existence but
of course it also adds to the amount of
debt
so as you rely more and more upon credit
the level of private debt Rises
you reach a point where that private
debt can't be serviced because many of
the ventures finances have been Ponzi
schemes that have failed or bad badly
thought out ventures to begin with the
level of credit drops and when it drops
you go from credit bursting demand to
credit actually subtracting from demand
now that's why I've started warning
about the crisis myself in 2005 the end
of 2005 and when Godley beat me by about
six years and had a fall beat me by a
couple of years plenty of people who
look at the level of debt private debt
and say that's the credit causes demand
and when it stops growing they'll be a
crisis we were the ones who warned about
the crisis and were ignored because he
weren't part of the mainstream so it's
extremely easy to unpack what caused the
crisis and when you do you come up with
policies that say you shouldn't
deregulate banks you should actually be
controlling the money creation powers
they have I think that that's a great
place to pause in exactly where I want
to pick up the conversation in part two
which relates to not only private debt
but even at the national level
discussions about debt and deficit and
where they go wrong we're speaking with
economist Steve Kean he has written a
number of books including debunking
economics and most recently can we avoid
another financial crisis and we'll
continue our conversation with him in
part two we're continuing our
conversation with Steve Keane who is an
economist professor at Kingston
University London he's authored several
books most recently can we avoid another
financial crisis and he is crowdfunded
on patreon at patreon.com slash PR of'
Steve Keen we left off part 1 talking
about debt and you were specifically
talking about private debt I have been
studying modern monetary theory for the
last couple of years and I want to get
your thoughts on at the federal level at
the government level debt deficit and
whether it is as I now increasingly see
it a political football that is not
objectively telling us anything about
how the economy is doing where do you
fall on the topic of the national debt
and deficit in terms of its relation to
evaluating how an economy is doing
pretty much aligned with non-monetary
theory but I take much more of a
perspective of the role of
banking sector and I start from there
they tend to start from the government
sector and I also work very much in
strictly monetary economics so I build a
software package I call Minsky that does
monetary modeling and an essential part
of a monetary vision is that if you look
at your financial situation you look at
your assets you look at your liabilities
and you look at your equity which is the
gap between your assets and your
liabilities and the fundamental rule of
accounting is the assets minus
liabilities minus equity equals zero and
banks financial institutions which
create money by levering up the equity
they have so they must have assets minus
liabilities being greater than being
greater than zero so they have positive
equity a bank goes bankrupt when it gets
negative equity if you look at if you
imagine that the sort of vision that a
lot of right wing commentators have
right-wing economists have Austrians in
particular that they should get rid of
government completely then you the only
source of money would be the banks
now if the banks must maintain assets
minus liabilities greater than zero by
definition the rest of society has to
have a negative equity and what is the
impact of that that the impact of that
is none of us want negative equity we'd
all like to have positive equity you
want to be able to say all my assets
minus liabilities is positive but you
have a banking sector which if it's the
only source of money it must have
positive otherwise the banks file there
for the rest of us the non-bank section
of the economy must have negative equity
but we all want positive equity so what
do we do we borrow money from the banks
gamble on rising asset prices and we
record the value of those assets as the
price the very last house sold for
multiplied by the entire stock of houses
as if we could all sell every last house
that exists for the price the last one
sold for totally fictional but that's
what convinces us we have positive
equity now as a result we get caught up
in bubbles Ponzi schemes and stuff like
that and if you look at what the
government does when you inject the
government into a scene like that the
government can actually handle having
negative negative equity nobody ever
goes and asks the Treasury or
Federal Reserve what's your net worth
net worth is the country called America
so they that they don't have the same
constraints that we have so what happens
when when a government spends it puts
money in your bank account when it taxes
it takes money out of your bank account
if it's spending exceeds its taxation
its injecting net equity into your bank
account and therefore you can reach your
goal of having positive equity without
letting to speculate on stock markets
and housing markets but because with
this this ideology this anti-government
ideology and because we think the
government is like a household and has
to tax before it can spend we end up
having those politicians trying to push
the government into running a surplus
now by definition if you divide the
world into sector a and sector B
whatever they are financially if sector
a has a positive equity secretary B has
a negative equity so the government's
trying to achieve positive equity for
itself it's driving us to the negative
equity which is one of the problems so
can we then get into the conversation
about when we point to the united states
is running XX sized deficit this year
for example does that objectively tell
us anything or does it matter what that
equity what that deficit came from in
other words it seems to me that if you
give a hundred billion dollars to the
richest 1% in tax cuts and go into
deficit for that they have a high
propensity to save that money because
they don't necessarily need it for
day-to-day spending and thus the
multiplier effect that you achieve with
that hundred billion dollars is
relatively low compared for example to
if you were to spend that hundred
billion on health care healthier people
work more meaning they earn higher wages
meaning the government collects more
payroll taxes and income taxes so is
that a reasonable assessment that not
every dollar of deficit means the same
thing is true but also at the aggregate
level the the level of the deficit which
is let's call it what it is it's the
excess of government spending over
taxation if you and I did that
indefinitely we'd be at we'd be bankrupt
it's a deficit for us but if you're got
the capacity to create money which of
course governments have
then it's a record of their money
creation over time and when you take a
look at it the if you make the White
House actually publishes a long term
series called America's I think the the
government surplus when you look at the
average level of that surplus per year
over the last 120 years the data starts
pretty much in 1900 the average level of
that surplus is minus 2.4 percent of GDP
in other words spending exceeds taxation
by about 2.4 percent of GDP for a
hundred and twenty years if you take out
the war years it falls to about 2.3
percent or 2.2 percent so the walls
don't make much difference so for a one
and a half one and a quarter centuries
the American government has been
spending more than it gets back in
taxation now critics of this say well
that's going to lead to a crisis extent
in the long run I think 120 years is a
long run in other words it's just part
of the normal functioning of government
it spends more than it gets back in
taxation by doing so it creates the
money the rest of us use for commerce so
there are critics of that who would say
and I think this gets us kind of back to
growth which you mentioned there are
those who will say well okay that that
might be true Steve a hundred and twenty
years of this record but we are on a
planet that is of some limited amount of
resources and at a certain point you
were going to reach that limit and at
that point is when it's all going to
implode what would you say to that
well that in fact is a physical
explanation that I completely agree with
but it's not a monetary explanation you
think about the theory it's all saying
we're going to run out of money you know
the bond vendor ladies will sinkers etc
etc that's just not going to happen but
what is going to happen as we are
running out of the physical capabilities
of this planet and therefore growth
itself is a problem and that's what
really matters and of course in that
situation if we are going to strike a
point and I think we're going to hit it
in the next 10 or 20 years where we
seriously have to reduce our energy
consumption on this planet then you want
to have lots of Engineers around and
lots of engineering capability lots of
scientists you want the capacity to
build new technology to start cooling
the earth after we've spent the last 250
300 years warming it up that takes
investment and unfortunately what we're
doing with the focus on reducing
the monetary deficit is we're actually
reducing our capacity to build those
resources when we'll need them in a very
short time in the future so I think
that's the monetary thing is extremely
and
resources are extremely important and
that's all being ignored because we
obsess about whether we're going to have
the money at the time yeah how do we
successfully push back against the
notion that in an economy in in economic
so to speak you don't really need to
consider what we're doing to the climate
or to the planet because basically it's
going to be sorted out yes there are
negative externalities but that it's all
going to be sort of naturally sorted out
by the market it seems intuitively wrong
to someone with my economic
sensibilities but somebody who has a
different economic sensibility might say
no listen we're always going to be
slightly ahead of the circumstances the
engineers and the corporation's will
always keep us slightly ahead of that
tipping point at which everything goes
bad
how can you push back against that it's
complete nonsense in so many words
because if that worked so we would
already have people developing the
technology just cause it to freeze
Antarctica again and to freeze Greenland
we would have people who have worked out
ways to extract carbon dioxide out of
the atmosphere and can do it profitably
selling us you know D decarbonization
technology it simply isn't true we are
massively behind the 8-ball on that
front and in fact it wasn't the market
system that is going to could have saved
us it could have been realizing via the
work of people like dan meadows and
Randers with the limits to growth that
this was a potential constraint for the
planet over the year for this society in
40 or 50 years time we could have
started building this technology back in
1973 we've taken them seriously and now
we have will ensure we have the
technology in hand instead corporate
interests in particular played a major
role in undermining their research and
we all know if an Exxon role in that
particular front of you know knowing
that global warming has been caused by
carbon dioxide and then suppressing your
research so the court the fight that
whatever you might describe an idealized
Austrian vision of a competitive market
it isn't what we've had it isn't how
things have happened and we are
incredibly badly prepared for that point
when it comes particularly it comes with
a bunch of runaway ecological processes
which we know if you look at the
literature on this area already starting
to occur and once they start happening
there is no way a market is going to
turn it around it'll be a militaristic
like a third world war against climate
that will be facing rather than a market
driven solution maybe this relates and
maybe it doesn't but can could you give
an example of a criticism of capitalism
that you think is an unfair one but then
also on the other side of that a
criticism of capitalism that you think
is a good one that we don't often hear
oh okay well the first one I think a lot
of people criticize capitalism because
of the diversity of products I say we
don't need 600 rounds of toothpaste etc
etc we don't need 30,000 in sexy that we
have tens of hundreds of thousands of
insects so an evolutionary system
produces diversity and out of the
diversity you get survival of the the
better-adapted not necessarily the
better but the better adapted so part of
the evolutionary process of capitalism
will generate that range of products and
I think we need what we have to look at
is you know do we need the plastics we
use etc etc rather than the diversity of
products so that's one area where I
think people criticize it without
realizing that they're criticizing it
for being an evolutionary system which
is partly why it succeeds and then how
about on the other side of that a good
criticism of capitalism that maybe is
not one that is popular in mainstream
media and popular culture I think most
of them are out there we just tend to
just we tend to discount them for bad
the reasons of bad economic theory so
I'll stick with the inequality one yeah
and that is that we we perceive
inequality and a lot of people think
that's bad and capitalism you know it
has too much inequality every society
every system has inequality to some
degree so inequality is as some of the
defenders of capitalism say and
necessary feature of this
I'm succeeding but at the same time we
have an excuse that says the inequality
is okay because we all actually earning
what we contribute to production and
this comes out of the egg of economic
theory with the argument that we receive
our marginal products so payments of
workers reflects the level of output
generated by the very last worker hired
and did over output the payment to
capitalists reflects the very last
dollar that capitalists created and that
then says whatever the inequality is
it's justified by the contribution to
production that is a total myth and it's
because when you look again to the
theory it's neat plausible and wrong but
I've just recently wrote a brilliant PhD
thesis by a guy called Blair thick's
highly recommend you having a talk to
him and Blair was trying to understand
the level of inequality saw in
capitalism and the marginal productivity
theory didn't work
nor did Marx's theories and so on and he
finally struck on the idea of saying
what actually causes inequality is Iraqi
the scale of hierarchy and hierarchies
that exists throughout human society you
can go right back to the very first
Sumerian civilizations and find
hierarchy there you come forward to
capitalism today an enormous hierarchy
here as well and if you then at the
hierarchy determine the pay then people
at the top of hierarchies people like
the bozos of the world and so on well in
an absolute fortune the ones down the
bottom get a pittance so once you
realize that it's a hierarchy thing the
question comes down just how rocky do we
want our societies to be and maybe
societies which have less hierarchy
actually function better so for example
you would all know you know the product
gore-tex sure and I've met the gore
family some time ago I might add they
organized their company on lines of a
hundred units of one hundred and fifty
people and the reason that hierarchies
developed is that about hundred and
fifty people is about all we can handle
in communication is what's called the
Dunbar number and they realize anything
beyond a hundred and fifty started to be
dysfunctional the level of hierarchy in
command and so on such as making work
less effectively so they looking at the
research they saw this thing about the
done by a number and they decided to say
I think ok all our factories are going
to work on the units of 150 people no
more and that is actually worked out to
be a better society for everybody
because fundamentally as human beings we
can only relate to about a hundred and
fifty people and that that sort of gives
you an idea that it isn't just
capitalism it says any large human
society gets to the stage where the
scale of it is so great that we start to
ignore people you walk past a homeless
person don't even think about it you
fill up a twinge of guilt that you leave
it at that where you feel a twinge of
superiority depending upon your
political orientation I think ultimately
we have to see that level of a hundred
and fifty people which we used to live
in communities of that size as what is
the ideal for humanity and we need to
find a way of making our societies
compatible with letting us relate to
that 150 people while not ignoring the
rest of the planet absolutely
fascinating we've been speaking with
Steve keen who is an economist you can
also check him out on patreon at
patreon.com forward slash PR of' Steve
Keen Steve a real pleasure speaking with
you today did that matter very much
enjoyed the conversation